well the the story just gets more and
more embarrassing for the media as we
continue to do this Cavanaugh thing for
a second time ringing ringing in the
anniversary of the Cavanaugh hearing by
rehashing all of it and so it's
appropriate I suppose that the media is
embarrassing itself humiliating itself
yet again because that's what it did the
first time and so now it's we're gonna
become a tradition annually this is what
they do we talked yesterday about this
debunked claim in the New York Times
about another alleged sexual assault
that happened 30 years ago though though
as I said yesterday even if this thing
actually happened which it didn't but
even if it did it wouldn't be sexual
assault even if it happened it wouldn't
matter if someone somehow forced
Cavanaugh's penis into a woman's hand at
a party as the story goes that would if
anything be sexual assault by the person
who did the forcing and Cavanaugh would
be one of the victims of it but however
that would work logistically I have no
idea I can't even figure out what the
accusation is supposed to be but then it
turns out that the woman the alleged
victim didn't want to be interviewed
about the incident and and and said she
didn't remember it she had no
recollection of it and yet the times
left that detail out of its report had
to go back and add in add in the
correction now the authors of the piece
are trying to trying to explain why that
detail was left out and they've thrown
their editors completely under the bus
which is kind of hilarious watch this
craft of the article did it include
those words that have since been added
to the article it's it it's so somewhere
in the editing process those words were
yeah I mean I think what happened
actually was that you know we had her
name and you know The Times doesn't
usually include the name of ricktum and
so I think in this case the editors felt
like maybe it was probably better to
remove it and in removing her name they
removed the other reference to the fact
that she didn't remember okay so the way
in your draft for the times you used
basically the exact words ever in the
book that I deliberately left off the
name because that passage begins with
the name
and so in their removal of the name they
ended up removing what follows yes Miami
so I think it was just sort of an
editing you know done in the haste in
the editing process as you know from
closing we're involved in the decision
to amend this and do the correction of
the addition on line to the piece we
discussed it yeah I mean we think we
felt like this there was so much heat
you know there's so much everyone has
been kind of seizing on various aspects
of this that we certainly didn't want
this to be an issue anymore and we
certainly never intended to mislead in
any way we wanted to give us full a
story as possible I think something
tells me these two probably aren't going
to be getting you know any more jobs
writing pieces for newspapers anytime
soon because throwing throwing your
editor under the bus is not ideal
and but are they right you know it are
the editors to blame well yeah the
editors are partly to blame but so are
they because here's the thing they
didn't speak up when the article was
published without that information they
didn't speak up and say hey wait a
second something was left out here this
is an important detail no they they they
said nothing they only said something
after other people discovered the
omission and brought it up that's when
they talked about it so I wish that
these people would just be honest and I
know that's too much to ask but I'd
almost respect it if they came out and
said hey listen we hate Cavanaugh
because he's pro-life and we're just
doing what we need to do to get rid of
them that's what this is about so that's
why we omitted it because obviously it's
not gonna help our case and that's what
we care about I would almost respect
that I would almost respect the honesty
if they just said that and and here's
the irony here by the way the left is
going through all this trouble to smear
Cavanaugh because they're afraid that
he's going to repeal Roe versus Wade and
that's and that of course is what this
is all about but but meanwhile Cavanaugh
almost certainly would not vote to
repeal roe v wade so all of their
hysterical fears are are completely
misplaced you know there's a reason why
most Pro lifers if you
attention when Cavanaugh was announced
most pro-lifers were not jumping for joy
they the way they would have been if for
example a me koni berry was word it was
was put up for the for the spot but with
Cavanaugh most pro-lifers were like yeah
hmm
that was our reaction now we started
rallying behind cabin all win all these
rape these fake rape accusation came out
they were trying to destroy his life and
destroys family and then and then of
course we're gonna rally behind him
because this is just to do that to any
any person is wrong but no he's there is
actually little evidence that Cavanaugh
is pro-life is a conservative pro-life
er for all we know and this actually is
my guess and this is why I wasn't too
excited about the nomination my guess is
that he's gonna when it comes to these
kinds of issues he's gonna be kind of
like a Kennedy basically liberal I I
would be if I if I had to put all all of
my money on on one outcome or the other
and if there was a roe v-- wade
challenge before the Supreme Court I
would definitely put my money on him not
voting to repeal it and but here's the
double irony the double irony is if
there's any chance of Kavanagh actually
voting against Roe and actually becoming
a social conservative on the bench it'll
it would probably be because of how he's
been treated by the left so they're
doing all this because they're so afraid
of how meanwhile he's a moderate
probably kind of liberal guy but but if
that changes it's gonna be because of
how he's being treated by them and their
their wager is that well they treat him
this way and he's gonna be too afraid
when it comes down to it he's gonna he's
just gonna do what they want because
they're he he'll be too afraid of
provoking their wrath which maybe is how
it would go I don't know but there's
also a possibility and this is what I
would root for that he says you know
what screw these people these people are
evil
now there is a real Cavanaugh related
bombshell one that shockingly was was
reported by CBS that's maybe the biggest
bombshell of all and we'll talk about
that in a minute but first we're never
gonna agree on everything but I think we
all can agree that we could all use a
lot more sleep sleep is well I don't
know if you knew this but it's an
essential human need you need sleep
getting a great night's sleep is easier
than ever thanks to the world's softest
sheets brought to you by our friends at
Boland branch everything Bolan branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time so it even gets
better and better as you use them
everyone who tries Boleyn branch sheets
loves them and that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews that's
all you have to do is go and see what
the people are saying about these sheets
and you'll see that that everyone loves
them and they want you to love your
purchase too so they offer a no risk
30-day trial and free shipping so you
could send it back and gonna like them
but you're not gonna want to do that
because these are amazing sheets to get
you started right now my listeners get
$50 off your first set of sheets at
Bowland and branch com promo code mat go
to Boleyn branch calm today for $50 off
your first set of sheets that's B oh ll
and branch dot-com promo code Matt
Boland branch comm promo code Matt okay
oh I forgot to mention one of the
reporters quote unquote who authored the
piece that is now being now being torn
apart and rightfully so is suggesting
that the alleged victim doesn't remember
what happened because she was drunk so
talk about victim blaming or alleged
victim blaming they've gone from
smearing the alleged perpetrator to
smearing the alleged victim whatever
they need to do I
whatever whatever needs to be said now I
predicted yesterday that that the the
the narrative from the left given the
fact that this alleged victim doesn't
remember it the narrative is gonna be
well she suppressed the memory because
it was so traumatizing she suppressed it
it's a suppressed memory so actually the
fact that she doesn't remember
is proof that he did do it because
that's exactly what you would expect and
in fact I did have some people on
Twitter tell me that that is an actual
argument that was presented to me that
she it's a suppressed memory but here's
another here's another way to go and say
wow she's drunk anyway because whatever
these people needs to do this is pure
evil and they're not gonna stop they
just will not stop speaking of evil
Leland Kaiser friend of Christine Ford
and one of the supposed witnesses at the
supposed party where this were her
alleged supposed rape occurred is
revealing something interesting and when
I say speaking of evil I don't mean
Leland Keyser as the evil I mean what
the what she's had to endure and what's
happening apparently behind the scenes
to this woman that's the evil part
shockingly CBS has this report watch
this Cavanaugh was narrowly confirmed
after a gut-wrenching day of testimony
from him and Christine Blasi Ford who
accused him of assaulting her at a
high-school party
speaking publicly for the first time to
the tines reporters Ford's close friend
Leland Kaiser who Ford said was at the
party said she didn't believe Ford's
account and that it just didn't make any
sense
she also said she told the FBI that
fours allies pressured her to say
otherwise so she doesn't believe it she
straight up just doesn't believe it and
this is a friend of Christine Ford and
this is someone who's a liberal Democrat
so there's no political motive for this
no financial or personal motive there
couldn't be because this is a friend
she's just a Lea nated herself from her
friends she's enduring all this abuse
behind the scenes now she doesn't gain
anything from this yet this is what
she's come out and said now someone said
to me yesterday oh well the fact that
you're saying that her not believing
Christine Ford is is is this huge a
significant thing but if she came out
and said she did believe Christine Ford
you'd probably say it didn't matter well
yeah kind of now if she had come out and
said I saw it I remember it I'm a
witness that would be significant but if
she just said as a friend yeah I don't
remember it but I but I believe her
which actually was what was originally
reported originally what was reported is
that Leland Kaiser there was always this
weird thing where she didn't want to
come out she didn't want to talk about
it she said she didn't remember but
originally reported by I think I think
was the Washington Post I don't remember
which out but it was originally reported
that Leland Kaiser said I don't remember
it but but yeah I believe her but it was
always weird that Kaiser was not more
public about about about coming out in
support of her friend just like Kristine
Ford's family that was always a weird
thing that her family didn't really come
out publicly in support of her always
very strange well now we find out behind
the scenes Kaiser was being was being
pressured and now she's saying you know
in honestly I don't believe her and yet
that to me is more significant than her
saying she believes her why is that well
because she's a friend so she has a very
obvious bias a very obvious personal
reason to say I believe her even if she
doesn't she has no obvious reason to say
she doesn't believe if she in fact does
so the fact that she's going against her
own interests against her own
friendships in order to say that that is
very very significant just like the
silence from Christine Ford's family not
coming out publicly and being out there
and supporting in a very really visible
way that is also significant so let's go
back and recap your Christine for it has
no witnesses no evidence doesn't
remember where it happened doesn't
remember when it happened just doesn't
remember what happened before or after
her own friend doesn't believe her
apparently her own family doesn't
believe her
there's just no reason at all period to
take her seriously or to take any of
this seriously so the people who are
still going around and claiming that
Cavanaugh is a rapist and so on these
are disgusting lying hacks all of them
they know what they're doing
they know exactly what they're doing and
we talked about we talked about how this
is backfiring on the left because it's
only aria in a lot of people's minds and
you hear this from from a lot of people
that they don't really like Trump they
even dislike him strongly but they're
still gonna vote for them because of
this kind of thing because of Cavanaugh
because they've seen of how they've seen
how the left acts and they realize I
have to do whatever they can to stop the
left from taking control you hear that a
lot and so the thought is well this is
backfiring on the left it's a really on
top of being morally wrong it's a really
bad strategic political move which i
think is correct but if there isn't but
there I think there is a strategy also
on on their side not saying it's a good
strategy but there is a strategy I think
part of the strategy is this is a
warning shot now this is real this is a
message to when Ruth Bader Ginsberg is
no longer on on the bench her
replacement this is a message to to
Ginsburg's replacement if that person is
nominated by a Republican like this is a
message you know if if you're nominated
you probably want to decline because you
see what we're gonna do to you I think
that's part of the strategy here and
that's why they keep going because
they're trying to say to the next
potential conservative nominee or
Republican nominee if you accept this we
are going to ruin your life and we are
never ever going to stop and it could be
an effective strategy as morally
abominable as it is I mean look if it
were me if if Trump came to me and said
we want to have you on the Supreme Court
which is unlikely to happen well
honestly I'd probably take it I'd have
to say yes but I think a lot of people a
lot of more normal people would would
would would probably say it's not worth
it I'm not gonna have my whole life
turned I'm gonna have my family
destroyed over this
so that's the strategy very very evil
okay well the speaking of evil the the
that's my second time I've used that
transition that's really my transition
from every that's that's always my
transition speaking of evil let's go to
the next evil thing yay
okay well the the woke Rage mob has
found another scalp they've claimed
another trophy Shane Gillis Shane Gillis
was hired by SNL he was supposed to be
an SNL cast member but when it was
announced of course
people had to go digging to see if he'd
ever said anything controversial because
this is what we do now someone is in the
news for a positive reason and so we go
and we dig through their closet for
skeletons and we say let's let's go find
a reason to hate this person oh this
this person is being this person as
being is is is is you know in getting
honored or something as good as
happening they're being promoted
something good is happening let's go
find a reason hey this person and so
that's why that's what happened
you know everyone complains that the
news only reports negative stuff and
that's true most of the time but here's
what happens when there's a positive
news story there's a positive news story
if someone makes it into the news for a
positive reason it's turned into
something negative because we find a
reason to hate that person so in this
case it turned out that Shane Gillis had
in the past made offensive remarks about
Asians on a cop on on a podcast on a
comedy podcast with another comedian he
used slurs about Asians and he made fun
of their accents and he was talking
about Chinatown in the city and and all
of that is it offensive sure is it funny
not really no I watched a segment I
didn't find it funny is it a joke though
yes obviously he's a comedian on a
comedy podcast doing a bit that that's
what that's what comedians do on podcast
it's a joke bad joke fine but still a
joke
doesn't matter to the Rage mob it never
does they demanded that Gilles get fired
and now he has been SNL cave predictably
as always this doesn't need to be a
conversation about whether about whether
you know the the c-word for Asians is
offensive or whatever I think yeah it's
offensive I don't think you should go
around saying that but but but but
here's the point so what I mean really
so what yes if we can establish let's
just say we establish he said that's
offensive he said something offensive
okay he did right okay he said something
offensive fine so what everybody in the
world everybody are seven billion people
in the world everybody in the world all
seven billion if they have the power of
speech they have all set offensive
things every single one you have whoever
you are watching this right now you have
said so many offensive things and you
know you have every single one of you
all of you me included me also now that
doesn't mean and you can say oh I've
never used that word though okay maybe
you never have I'm not saying everyone's
used that word all right I'm not even
saying everyone's used racial slurs
maybe maybe you've never said offensive
things in that vein maybe that is not a
brand of offensive thing maybe that's
not a genre of offensive remark that you
have ever engaged in I'm perfectly
willing to believe that but on whatever
topic in whatever way you have said very
offensive things you have said things
that you wouldn't want plastered all
over the headlines you have said things
that you wouldn't want people digging
for and and and and and putting out
there the moment that you're promoted or
given a new job or whatever you you you
definitely definitely definitely have
and how do I know that well because
you're a person okay you're a human
being and that's just that's a thing
people do people say a lot of stuff in a
given day right if if you're a human
being and you can speak you say a lot of
things in it
you say even more things in a month even
more than that in a year and a certain
percentage of that stuff is going to be
offensive that's just the way it goes
that's statistics so it doesn't make
sense if when you think about it really
doesn't make sense when we find out that
someone said something offensive for us
to go what he said something offensive
what how is this possible this is
outrageous
of course he did like I mean it's of
course he did it was statistically
certain that he has said some offensive
stuff and and if you're someone now if
if you're not in the public eye at all
if you're not in media if you're not a
comedian if you're not whatever then
then probably the offensive things that
you've said for the most part have not
been on camera but if you're someone who
does a lot of talking on camera on
microphones and podcasts doing
interviews doing this and that now
you're on stage and doing this there's
just a lot of there's a huge volume of
material of you talking often
off-the-cuff then it's just it is
statistically certain that some of that
is going to be offensive and again if
you don't have video of you saying
offensive things floating around out
there that's only because you're not on
video that often so it just doesn't make
sense well I I think the proper reaction
with this kind of thing is for us to say
okay yeah well okay we all say offensive
things that's his offensive thing that
he said it's out there you know he
shouldn't have said it he did why can't
that just be the reaction he shouldn't
have said it he did though it's a that
you know we all say things we shouldn't
say that's dead here's an example here
is example number five hundred and fifty
two trillion of people saying things
they shouldn't say I mean he came out
and he said now if his response to this
was for him to come out and say oh no
you know what I really hate Asians I
despise them and you know and I stand by
up and bubble if he had done that then
then yeah
when heaven I couldn't even quibble with
SNL firing him but that's not what he's
said he came out and said look it was a
joke as a bad joke you know that's
that's what it was it was a bad joke why
isn't that enough why isn't that enough
he acknowledged it he says bad joke yeah
you got me you got me that was a thing
shouldn't have said it
I did why can't we just move on for that
I mean these are all rhetorical
questions I get it I know I know why and
I also know as I have myself pointed out
so many times that this is all
performative nobody is really outraged
nobody really cares because what I'm
saying right now everybody knows this
right so everyone people that act
offended by an offensive comment they
all know about themselves at oh man I've
I've said we're stuff than that about
about this or that you know they all
know that but they pretend to be what I
never I never this is it it's just
they're pretending it's performance why
do we pretend I don't know
power control Envy I think that's part
of it just the because we're bored it's
just something to do a lot of it is
recreational it is it is back in back in
the Roman days you could go to the
Colosseum and you could watch someone
get torn apart by the Lions and you
could get your kicks that way well we
don't have that anymore I have no doubt
that if we had something like that it
would be enormous ly popular but we
don't have that anymore so instead we
have this it's just it's it's bloodlust
its enjoying the watching someone get
torn apart if not physically then at
least metaphorically we can we can
settle for that
this as always this is where the Bible
once again has something to say about it
and you go to the famous story the he
without sin cast the first stone because
really at the end of the day you know
it's it's and the point of that story
but he without sin cast the first stone
Jesus wasn't saying we cannot
objectively make judgments about what's
right or wrong he wasn't saying this
woman was caught in adultery Jesus
wasn't saying despite how it's commonly
translated or interpreted these days he
wasn't saying oh no you know what
actually adultery is okay and he wasn't
saying the people that were disgusted by
outraged by by adultery and opposed it
or whatever
it wasn't saying they were wrong for
that yeah the adultery is wrong so I
said go and sin no more to the woman
it's wrong but he's also saying you're
not really in a place that to literally
throw a stone at this woman because look
at yourself
yeah maybe you've never committed
adultery maybe maybe that's not the you
know it with your maybe that's not a
type of sin that you've committed but
you've done things to you've done really
bad things so adultery is a really bad
thing you have certainly done really bad
things in your life maybe not that but
something else and so you're just not
you're not the guy
if there's anyone around here who can
throw a stone it's not you I think that
applies very much in these in these
situations
let he who has never made an offensive
comment in their life not singing not a
single one let he be the one to cast the
stone alright one more thing Sean Spicer
speaking of evil no you may you may
remember him this isn't so much evil as
just-just-just
said this is sad so Sean Spicer was a
former White House press secretary and
as you may recall Trump's
secretary and he's on Dancing with us
with the Stars now for some reason and
he debuted his he did his debut dance
last night I admit I don't watch the
show but I did see this clip online and
I just have to share it with you watch
this
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now in fairness in fairness I do have
that exact shirt I must admit for those
listening on itunes spice Spicer's is
wearing a fluffy frilly neon shirt while
doing the salsa I think that's supposed
to be the soul so I'm not really sure
that he's dancing to the spice girls so
I don't know but it's his dance moves
look like well they first of all they
look like I would look if I was trying
to do the salsa which is why I would
never do it especially not on camera but
he looks really he looks like he looks
like a little league baseball coach
having a seizure in a pirate shirt
that's that's kind of what his salsa
looks like and I I don't get it but but
Mike Huckabee Mike Huckabee who thank
God has not gone on the show yet he
wrote on Twitter in support of a Sean
Spicer and he said want to create an
emotional meltdown in Hollyweird
Hollyweird instead of Hollywood clever
stuff vote for Sean Spicer to win
Dancing with the Stars tonight and every
night that he's on Sean Spice is a good
guy and a brave sport to go on Dancing
with the Stars let's show him some love
and then Spicer responded thank you Mike
Huckabee clearly the judges aren't going
to be with me let's send a message to
Hollywood that those of us who stand for
Christ won't be discounted may god bless
you he really tried to turn this into a
into a Jesus thing so he's really
claiming that he's standing with Christ
by dancing to the Spice Girls in a
frilly neon shirt that's that's easy
that's what I don't see me I don't get
it I don't quite get the connection when
I see that when I look at that clip I
see a guy who's desperate for attention
and once that still wants to be famous
and will do literally anything for it I
don't really see them gospel being
spread quite I don't I don't see where
that comes in and this is the thing that
we talked about victim culture and and
how Vic
hood has been turned into a currency
these days and everyone wants to be a
victim and and and we put that on the
left most of the time and for good
reason but it's not just the left that
does this and this is something that you
see among conservative Christians
sometimes I have to admit there there is
a tendency sometimes where Sean Spicer
now is turn himself into a victim where
you know the judges didn't like his
dance moves and it's because he's a
Christian no it's because you suck at
dancing Sean which look I do too so I'm
not but that's why again I don't I'm not
gonna do it in front of judges I'm not
gonna do in front of anybody
in fact I I you know we're going to a
wedding this weekend and this will be
the second wedding that I've attended
while after my Achilles injury and in
both cases these are times where I
actually thank God that I have an
Achilles injury even though now I'm kind
of overcoming it but I still have it but
I thank God for it because it's my
excuse I don't have to dance um I can
just sit there which is what I would do
anyway in fairness but and now I have a
reason and I can sigh was that when it
was the last the first one I went to is
I would still have to cast on everything
and people are dancing people are coming
up to me and I was saying oh man I'd
love to be out there I'd love to be out
there dancing I'll tell live to dance
but you know I just can't I just can't
it's it's it really it's tough for me to
sit here and not be able to dance
anyway so that that's my theory my
theory for Sean is that is that they
they didn't like the dancing because
it's bad not because they're against
Christ and so this victimhood thing now
there are there are examples of
conservative Christians in this country
being victimized there are many more
examples across the world of Christians
actually being victimized and martyred
in this country it does happen talk to
talk to masterpiece cake shop Jack
Phillips and he'll tell you about that
but there are also examples of the
victimhood mentality among Christians
where you know so and someone is
insulted or or or whatever and they try
to turn it into and I don't I don't
think
we should do that I think it's it's
almost blasphemous really that's almost
blasphemy don't bring you know that's
spectacle there okay if you want to do
that do it but don't bring Jesus into
that yeah anything to do with that don't
blame him
why do people I really don't I don't
understand you know this thing that that
people do where they when you've got F
list celebrities who someone who's
famous you know for being a White House
press secretary or former White House
President and then they in and they they
go and they embarrass themselves on TV
intentionally just to keep the attention
on them I don't understand it how are
you that desperate for attention that
you'll even take negative attention that
I don't get if somebody came to me and
said hey would you love to come out
would you like to come on this show here
and be humiliated in front of everybody
I would have to say not really no thanks
for the offer
are you sure cuz millions people gonna
be watching you could be really really
embarrassed yeah no no thanks I don't
think so
i humiliated myself all the time as it
is and sometimes on camera as anyone who
watches this show can attest I don't
need help
alright let's go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com although all that being said I
do the other part of me does have some
kind of respect for people who are very
bad dancers like me and yet are willing
to do it in front of other people I do
have some respect for that I have to say
all right let's go to emails again Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com this is from
Rebecca says Matt I was wondering if you
could tell us your thoughts on the
conversation among Christians following
the recent suicide of the very
successful young pastor Jared Wilson
it's very hard for some of us to
understand why someone in his position
would want to end their own life yes
depression most often is never about
circumstances but when you're young have
a beautiful wife two healthy young kids
and success above the ordinary it's
really baffling now even some Christians
are saying that he didn't choose to
commit suicide but that he lost his
battle and died by suicide
many in quotes died by suicide many are
also saying that because he professed to
believe in Jesus that he's also that
he's automatically in heaven that and
that he's quote finally free if that
were the consequence of suicide should
we all do it then I'm not saying that he
is or isn't in heaven but how can we
know for sure and why would we even
assume to not murder is one of the 10
commandments a murder of the self is
self murder as a Catholic I believe in
hope he is in purgatory but irregardless
I don't think Christians should ever
advertise to the world that suicide is a
solution every single day it seems like
more and more Christians are not
standing on the foundation of truth too
scared to offend anyone I really like to
know what you think of all this Thanks
yeah Rebecca I've gotten a few emails
about this since I wanted to address it
this is an awful situation obviously I
didn't know Jared personally at all we
had we debated once on a podcast years
ago and that was pretty much the extent
of our interaction I think we interacted
maybe on Twitter a few times but by all
accounts a decent guy good guy and this
is just terrible it's I can't it's the
kind of thing you hear stories like this
it kind of takes your breath away when
you think about especially the family
wife and two kids and how they're why it
puts me at a loss for words when I think
about where you go as a spouse after
something like this as a child
it's just terribly tragic so you raise
two points which I think are important
and which also troubled me greatly and
it is a delicate subject and if people
get upset when you start talking about
these things and they say well you
shouldn't be talking about them or you
should talk about it now so well we know
we're gonna talk about it because you
got it we we need to talk about and the
two points you raised I think are good
important so one is this idea that we
should completely remove the choice the
will
fullness from suicide and talk about it
talk about it as if someone who quote
dies by suicide might as well died of
cancer and this is something now where
you hear this that that every time
there's a suicide of a prominent person
you hear from the media and social media
people saying no don't say he committed
suicide say died by suicide to make it
into a passive and to sound like
something that happened to him rather
than something that he did and I'll tell
you why that concerns me I think
probably for the same reason it concerns
you Rebecca because it makes the person
here's what I think about it makes the
person who is depressed who feels
hopeless whoever that might be there are
a lot of people in that boat right now
someone in that boat I don't see how it
doesn't make them feel powerless I mean
think about what you're saying to a
potentially suicidal person you're
saying you have no choice you have no
power to prevent this from happening you
have cancer essentially and and there's
nothing you can do suicide might just
happen to you like getting hit by a car
might just happen you can't stop it you
can't prevent it and I really worry that
might that might lead to more suicides I
worry that it does lead to more suicides
I worry that the way that we talk about
suicide of prominent people the way the
conversation happens and the things
people say and I know they say it with
with good intentions I know that but I
really worry that it caused that causes
the wrong word that it that it helps to
promote an atmosphere that encourages
suicide I think I think the the the
worst thing that you can do for someone
who is on the verge of of that is make
them feel powerless because they already
feel powerless they already feel like I
have no choice I have to do this so how
for us to respond and say you're right I
just think that's extremely dangerous
extremely now I get why we use this
language we don't want to be seen as
blaming or condemning we don't wanna
seem disrespectful we don't want to add
to the family's pain I'm very
sympathetic to that
I get that I do I really do but we have
to think also about we have to think
about the living we have to think about
the next potential person who might go
down that road what do they need to hear
I think we need to think about that more
and I think you have no choice you have
no power is a terrible message for them
it's the worst thing you could say to
them think about someone who is
literally standing on a Ledge and
they're about to jump would you ever say
to them you have no choice you have no
power this might just happen to you your
message would be the opposite right
wouldn't it be no you don't have when
they're screaming down to you from the
ledge I have no choice I have to do this
there's no way out aren't you saying no
you do have a choice you don't have to
do this there is a way isn't that your
message to them
isn't that what anyone would say well if
that's what we would say then isn't that
what we should say as for saying he's in
peace he's with Jesus again yeah I see
your concern because that that does seem
to promote suicide i and nobody means it
that way of course but how would it not
well if that's the case so you commit
suicide just go right to heaven and then
why why why don't we all do it then
heavens definitely better than earth and
so so why even treat suicide like a sad
thing in that case now at the same time
of course we're not gonna sit here and
say everyone who does that is not in
heaven right we're not going to say that
either I'm not saying that I and you
didn't say that
nobody can say that I think we we can't
say where anybody is no matter how they
died even if they did die by cancer no
matter how anyone died we can't say
where anyone is or what happened to
anyone after death and so I think it's
best to just leave that alone for
everybody and not make definitive
declarations about where they are what
happened or we can't because we're not
God we can't do that it's best to say
you know we could say what we hope and
what we pray and all of
but I think we should as much as
possible refrain from saying things that
we know we can't possibly actually know
to be true anyway it's a delicate
subject as I said but an important one
and the main thing here is is you know
we pray for his family and encourage
anyone who's feeling like Jared was
feeling at the end to encourage them to
seek help to get help to talk to
somebody you know you don't have to be
alone even if you feel alone you don't
have to be alone you're not and there is
help out there and suicide is just never
a solution to anything all right and and
and to look and see when when this kind
of thing happens and you look and you
see the the families that are left
behind which proves you know these are
people who felt alone but obviously
we're not we're very we're very very far
from being alone in fact they had their
lives were incredibly important and
integral to the lives of so many other
people who now will have this massive
hole in their lives that will never ever
be filled all right um this is from so
much time we have here this is from Jean
says dear Matt due to my long commute
each day I listen a daily wire as
follows been on my way home Michael in
the evening while cooking dinner and you
on my morning commute this morning yeah
that's a good system if you need to cut
the other two out just listen to me
you listen to me three times if you
wanted to I'm just saying it's it's up
to you this morning while in
bumper-to-bumper traffic I was laughing
out loud listening to you talk about the
Ravens game bathroom dilemma with your
son the people in the cars next to me
probably all thought I was a nutjob due
to laughing sorry I'm glad you didn't
have to crawl in urine me too you also
discussed your pet peeve of not being
able to watch people eat bagels one of
my pet peeves is rubberband
give me the creeps I won't touch them I
avoid them as much as possible would you
mind sharing your top 5 pet peeves
I appreciate your new unique perspective
insight and commentary on our news and
culture keep us a fantastic job you're
doing yeah some people ask me why do you
have a pet peeve about bagels it's just
the way they sound when people are
eating them I don't know what it is just
the kind of this kind of like swishy
squishy kind of sound people make when
they I can't describe it the sound of
people eating chips or something crunchy
that doesn't really bother me but
something that there's just I know I
can't I it's a pet peeve that's the
point I can't really explain why it
annoys me so much but it does as far as
my other Pepe's I can't rank them
because honestly everything's a pet be
for me everything annoys me I can find a
reason to be annoyed by anything and
everything in life it's one of my great
talents if you can really call it a
talent so I don't even know if I can if
that's a question I can answer but I
appreciate the question this is from LJ
says Matt what do you think of the rule
change in the NFL allowing challenges on
pass interference I think the NFL is
like Congress where they get together
every year and they feel like they just
have to do so they have to pass laws and
change things and they just because well
we're together we might as well when
really with Congress I always say people
complained O'Connor isn't doing anything
good that's what we want we don't want
them just pass laws for the sake of it
might as well pass some laws fellas
that's not good and the NFL does the
same thing where every year they just
they make rule changes because because
they have to I because they feel like
they have to or they feel like they they
might as well and those rule changes are
almost always bad they almost always
make the game worse except for this rule
change I totally support it I think pass
interference calls lucky give coaches
three challenges I think let them
challenge whatever they want
it's not like you know you're not giving
them 50 challenges or unlimited but they
have three and they should be able to
challenge anything that affects the
outcome of the game
the idea that the calls made by the refs
should be above challenge is to me so
absurd is so ridiculous that it doesn't
make any sense it passed
farrance call has is an enormous ly
important call and it can really affect
the outcome of the game it can it can
lose or win a game in the end and if an
erroneous pass interference is called
think about a pass interference if it's
a spot foul pass interference that could
that could be a fifty five yard penalty
and if it was wrong and if the ref was
wrong and there was no pass interference
of course we should be able to go we
have the technology to go back and look
at it and so of course we should it's
worth a couple of minutes to look at it
rather than just saying I'll give him
the fifty five yards that could be there
could be a difference with winning and
losing a game and you want as much as
possible to minimize having refs be the
ones who win or lose games because
nobody's watching for that that destroys
the product nobody's watching to see
what the rest do the refs are supposed
to be as much as possible invisible some
there are people who argue while human
error as part of the game
yeah human error of the players if
players are making mistakes then yeah
that's part of the game but mistakes by
the refs that is only by default part of
the game it's just it's part of the game
because we have in a day any way of
removing it from the game but if we can
remove those human errors by the refs as
much as possible we should do it finally
is this from Rose says Matt I've been a
fan for a long time but no more your
comment on chick-fil-a was beyond the
pale you should be ashamed yeah I said
on Twitter yesterday and it was I think
someone told me I was trending on
Twitter briefly because of people were
attacking me because I said that
chick-fil-a is overrated I stand by what
I said and the treatment that I have
gotten only brings to mind what Jesus
said in the Gospels blessed are those
who are persecuted for righteousness
speaking of victim and Tally's by
Christians there you go
no I look I'm not saying that
chick-fil-a is bad when I call something
overrated that doesn't mean it's bad it
just means that it's overrated it means
that it's not as good as everyone says
chick-fil-a is a good fast food place
like it I go to it I think it's top five
it's not number one that's all I'm
saying it they do a good chicken
sandwich that's all they really do that
well the I think their fries are not
good they're not crispy enough they're
too greasy they're undercooked much of
the time they're probably ten different
fast food places that do better fries
than chick-fil-a but they got the
chicken saying they do a good chicken
sandwich and it is good it's the best
chicken sandwich on the market but you
know it's a chicken sandwich and so it's
just it's it's they don't have a
diversity in the menu which is fine
because this is what they do but a
really good chicken sandwich is not
going to be is not going to be better
than for instance a really good
hamburger so I'm gonna take a place that
does a really good hamburger because
hamburgers are superior to chicken
sandwiches and they're gonna be above
chick-fil-a so that's why five guys four
examples of bub chick-fil-a chipotle if
you if you don't mind the the e.coli
every once in a while
Chipotle is better than chick-fil-a you
know Arby's I got news for you is better
than chick-fil-a chick-fil-a is a top
five place and they got great service
the fact that all the protests and
everything and the freaked out by the
left that does make the stuff tastes
better okay so when you when you when
you're eating the chicken sandwich and
you're thinking about how it makes a
leftist cry that does make it taste
better but still it doesn't quite put
them over the hump to get them into the
top three I'd say they're you know
number four or five and list very solid
they're never gonna get into that top
three because chicken sandwiches can
only bring you so far in life
unfortunately and and listen chicken is
just never gonna be beef it's always
gonna be chicken and so it's always
gonna be behind the places that excel in
beef and that's look these are facts
okay I'm not you you can react however
you want but but what I'm telling you
these are just scientifically proven
facts all right we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching have a
great day and we'll talk
tomorrow Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is
produced by Robert Sterling associate
producer alexia Garcia Del Rio executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you